we're told that lauren uses a blend of
dark roast beans and light roast beans
to make coffee at her cafe
she needs 80 kilograms of beans in total
for her next order
dark roast beans cost three dollars per
kilogram
light roast beans cost two dollars per
kilogram and she wants to spend 220
dollars in total
then they tell us here's a graph that
shows a system of equations for this
scenario where x is the number of
kilograms of dark roast beans she buys
and y is the number of kilograms of
light roast beans she buys all right let
me scroll down so we can take a look at
this
and so sure enough so this blue line and
i'll write it out in blue
this x is the number of kilograms of
dark roast beans y is the number of
kilograms of light roast beans and she
wants to buy a total of 80 kilograms
that's what they told that's what they
told us up here we can go back to look
at that
she
needs under lenses in blue she needs 80
kilograms of beans
so that constraint that the sum of the
kilograms of dark and light is equal to
80. that's represented by this equation
and if we were to graph it that is this
blue line right over here
and then this other constraint
3x well the dark roast beans cost three
dollars per kilogram so 3x is how much
she spends on dark roast 2y is how much
she spends on light roast because it's
two dollars per kilogram and 220 is the
amount that she spends in total and they
tell us that
up here
dark roast beans cost three dollars per
kilogram light roast beans cost two
dollars per kilogram and she wants to
spend 220 dollars so this equation is
another way of expressing what i just
underlined up here in green
and the green line shows all of the x y
combinations
that would match these constraints
and so now let's do something
interesting they've labeled some points
here point c d f and e and we're going
to think about what do each of these
points represent so for example this
point c that is on the green line
but it sits above the blue line
what does this tell us what does this
point c represent pause this video and
think about it
well if we're on the green line that
means that the amount that she spends on
dark roast plus the amount that she
spends on light roast is adding up to
exactly 220 dollars so she's definitely
spending 220 dollars at c
but how much how many total kilograms is
she using
well the fact that for
this given x we're sitting above the
line
that means that she's not using exactly
80 kilograms and we can see that over
here she's using looks like 10 kilograms
of dark and it looks like something like
95 kilograms of light if you were to add
those two points together it looks like
she's using something closer to 105
kilograms so point c is a situation
where she is spending exactly 220
dollars but she's using more than 80
kilograms
because it's not meeting this second
constraint it's sitting above that line
now let's think about point d what does
that represent pause the video and try
to figure that out
well because we sit on the blue line
that means that we are meeting this
constraint that the kilograms of dark
and light combined is equal to 80
kilograms
so she's using exactly 80 kilograms here
but what about her spending
well because this point lies below the
green line that tells us that we are
spending less than
220 dollars and we could even try it out
three times 20 plus 2 times 60 is what
60 plus 120 is 180
and so this is a point where we're
meeting this constraint but we're not
meeting this constraint we're
underspending right over here
now what about point f
well point f sits below both of these
lines so pause your video and think
about what that means
well if we're sitting below both of
these lines that means that neither are
we spending 220
nor are we using 80 kilograms and you
could see that if you actually look at
the numbers you don't have to do this
but this is just to make you feel good
about it it looks like she is using 30
kilograms of dark and 30 kilograms of
light so in total she is using so this
is a situation where she's using 60
kilograms in total not 80. and so that's
why we're not sitting on this blue line
and if you look at how much she's
spending she has 30 kilograms of each so
3 times 30 plus 2 times 30 that's going
to be 90
plus 60 that's also less than 220 and so
that's why we see this point is below
these lines
and then last but not least what does
point e
represent well point e sits on both of
these lines so that means that it meets
both of these constraints this is a
situation where she is spending exactly
220
and the total number of kilograms she's
using of dark and light is exactly 80.
and so if we wanted to say hey what
combination of dark and light would she
need in order to meet both constraints e
represents that the intersection of
these two lines